you're in for okay so three three or ten
give it to me eight first try gone
it's a nine second try
it's an ace no third try
i should have come today too uh we have
two
world champions playing this fun variant
of chess it's called
card chess where you can see this card
right here guys it is
all right guys we can all see the game
and it's white to move because white
moves first and it is
a seven we should be the white pieces
it's seven so
the pawn on okay that's great right oh
yeah oh no
no no seven is f right seven is f point
right oh yeah yeah okay
uh okay so let's let for the rest of the
game
eight is the uh g pawn and
and and seven minus the edge point okay
oh yeah
saying okay this one will let it go all
right all right cool so it's five
you see how i avoided the birds opening
there
okay should i go d6 or okay i'll go b6
so it's a ten it's a ten yeah
very good seven no seven is e pawn right
no seven f f1 sorry but that's not
possible
three three that's double team kettle
wow
oh wow it's a king
[Laughter]
oh man look at that yeah
you have to get six right you have to
get the number six six or king
why six six or five no five is deep one
right
ah yeah sure so king king or five king
or five yeah oh yeah yeah it is
a six oh so that first try is gone
that's good
first try is gone it's at three
also gone
this is the last try i can't believe it
it's a pen
[Laughter]
sequence of moves i i get the king he
gets the knight
okay guys so magnus has lost this one
and
she has won this one already wow how
about that magnus how about that
that was uh that was like wandering into
a background checkmate okay
see 95 was brilliant
i think i have to admit i wasn't sure
what it was trying to do to me but that
was a good idea
i'm so glad you played 95 you took the
risk and now max is down
so this is the shortest game of magnus
now
yeah we have one more
one one more card let's do one more card
one more card
okay okay okay i see magnus wants to win
this so badly
should have conducted 2013 world
championship with car chester
it's a seven it's a seven very good
i'm opening up to a check already i can
see where this is going
i mean if you haven't if you have moved
your e-pawn then
you would have checked me and the game
would have been overall yeah yeah you
could have won actually if i quit
six no
[Laughter]
and now you have a jack and a jack
why are you doing this to me oh
[Music]
it's all going pretty well for me so
yeah the last few moves i've got my
bishop back
i got a lot of space e6 now there's no
more
check on g4 and you don't have any
so you have a king i have a king
wow okay that was
i don't know maybe that wasn't good
okay it's a two come on come on
oh that is too safe should have gone a b
and then b3
it's a three yes yes yes
okay this this is going my way now
queen down one more tree
it's a queen
come on come on it's a jack okay
i'll take it jack is bishop
oh
oh okay this is a tricky choice actually
aces look i i would go r3 rook c3
why not i mean just give a check why not
what's the harm
okay
okay brooker knight recognized okay now
magnus needs
a 10 minute acer 10 or an
ace and let's see what he has he has an
edge
oh thanks for the advice we did
sorry give me an eight come on
eight it's an eight yeah
this
[Music]
so guys in five moves magnus has to get
a king
otherwise he's lost all right number one
move is
six nah no drama just read any number
it's 10. go on
what it's queen it's a king
come on the game continues
you know that's why i thought that's why
i thought queen edge to check would have
been uh
92 92 all night move yes yes but your
queen is also safe
like next move you can next you're still
not making it
like you still have position it's a five
the d pawn
yes yes yes okay now one more
time the white's odds are very good now
any emu is good for him
yeah c6 rook b8 987 all moves are good
for
even the material is kind of equal you
know that doesn't matter in this game
king safety it's all about that it's
queen
queen
oh king is very dangerous why oh
because anywhere he goes there is a
check on next move it can be there
if i go to c2 rook c7 i can take with
pawn or
knight or i can move the queen yeah i
mean it's the same even if you go on a2
or c2 it's the same
yeah ace aces
oh oh we have it again
it's very risky this time yeah
okay so three three or ten give it to me
eight first try gone
it's a nine second try
it's an ace no third try
i should have gone to a2
it's a queen come on
last one i still believe this is the
last one little little build up for this
one the
last one and three two
one it's a five
[Music]
gg
i dodged the dangerous checks and then i
get this one
and i cannot i cannot get a three or a
ten or a king in five tries
but this is a great game right that's a
great game
what a game what a game uh that was damn
fun that was so much fun
uh thank you so much for joining
[Music]
you